an 88 year old congressperson gets hit
with sexual harassment allegations and
we will explain how Congress people get
away with it plus so does Oliver Stone
and so does Charlie Rose so pretty much
everybody is getting hit with sexual
harassment allegations and that's
because everything is hot garbage we'll
explain why I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so I guess that we have to set that
workplace counter back to zero you know
like the one that says no sexual
harassment allegations today we have to
set that one all the way back to zero
from one yesterday every single day
there are new prominent people who are
being hit with sexual harassment
allegations who will go through them
we'll also explain how it is that
Congress gets away with X they have this
very sophisticated system where you're
not able to detect which Congress people
were actually sexually harassing or
sexually molesting to help we'll talk
about that plus I do want to get to a
theory that I have going about why it is
that modern society has has actually
seems to have accentuated the incidence
of sexual harassment and sexual assault
we'll talk about that in just a second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at bull and branch so I'm
Bolin branch these are the folks who
make the best sheets in the world I mean
I am NOT a good sleeper as you know I've
said many times I'm very bad at sleeping
particularly when I'm on the road I'm
bad at sleeping when I'm at home I sleep
much better because I have bull and
branch sheets these are so comfortable
that you cannot sleep in any other
sheets after I mean it spoils sleep for
you
bolon branch sheets they're breathable
they are super comfortable they don't
stick to you you don't feel like you're
slipping in the tarp that you don't
sweat into them and they're just great
bowline branch sheets they're used by 3x
presidents Plus presumably Bill
Clinton's lovers and check it out at
bowl and branch comm there are five
stages of sleep before you need it
before you enter any of them you need
bull and branch you will love them try
them for 30 nights to see for yourself
if you're not impressed return them for
a full refund and that's why they have
thousands of five-star views because
their product is so good go to bowl and
branch com2 it's Bo ll and branch comm
today and you will get 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets plus free shipping
when you use promo code Ben 50 bucks off
plus free shipping bull and branch com
promo code Ben again that's while Bo ll
and branch com promo code Ben go check
it out it's a terrific product I mean
why would we bought that we bought extra
sheets for the guest room we bought what
for the the kids rooms I mean they're
just they're just awesome okay so let's
talk about the latest allegations of
sexual harassment and sexual assault so
the latest allegations are against John
Conyers anyone who is surprised by this
has not been following politics very
long the Michigan representative John
Conyers was caught on a plane a few
years back looking at playboy so it is
not particularly shocking that John
Conyers
a guy who was who was trying to hit up
the help according to documents obtained
from documents obtained by BuzzFeed news
they've obtained a bunch of documents
from a complaint it's it there's a woman
who who filed who settled a wrongful
dismissal complaint in 2015 from Conyers
she says she was fired because she would
quote not succumb to his sexual advances
in 2015 I have to say I don't know what
it is about Congress is there something
that you know in enlivens the prostate
in Congress but is there really like is
there something in politics that just
allows men's prostates to work longer
than normal because John Conyers in 2015
was 86 years old and was apparently
hitting up the interns for sexual favors
but I hope that you know I hope
everything is all the plumbing is
working correctly for me when I'm that
age but I also know that I'm not gonna
be hitting up 20 year old interns when
I'm 86 years old and then in case
documents from the complaints obtained
by BuzzFeed news include four signed
affidavits three of which are notarized
from former staff members who allege the
Conyers the ranking Democrat on the
powerful House Judiciary Committee
repeatedly made sexual advances to
female staff that included requests for
sex acts contacting and transporting
other women with whom they believed
Conyers was having affairs caressing
their hand sexually and rubbing their
legs and backs in public for people
involved with the case verify the
documents or authentic and the documents
also show there's the important part the
secret mechanism by which Congress has
kept an unknown number of sexual
harassment allegations secret a grinding
closely held process that left the
alleged victim feeling she told BuzzFeed
news that she had no option rather than
to stay quiet and accept a settlement
offer to her she said I was basically
blackballed there was nowhere I could go
BuzzFeed is withholding the woman's name
at her request because she fears
retribution last week the Washington
Post reported that Congress's office of
compliance paid out 17 million dollars
for 264 settlements with federal
employees over 20 years for various
violations including sexual harassment
but these new documents show exactly how
this works so the woman who settled with
Conyers launched the complaint is
growing BuzzFeed news with the office of
compliance in 2014
alleging that she was fired for refusing
his sexual advances and ended up facing
a daunting process that ended with the
confidentiality agreements in exchange
for a settlement to more than 27 grand
which by the way is a nothing settlement
I mean if you if you were wrongly fired
after your boss demanded sex from you
you only get two
and grin that is a noting of a
settlement the settlement came from a
Conyers office budget rather than the
designated fund for settlements Congress
doesn't have an HR department instead
congressional employees have 180 days to
report a sexual harassment incident to
the office of compliance which then
leads to a lengthy process involving
counseling and mediation and requires
the signing of a confidentiality
agreement before a complaint can go
forward so you can't even complain you
actually have to go direct to a court
and try to sue or you have to go through
this compliance process that requires
you to keep your cases secret which is
really horrifying after this an employee
can choose to take the matter to federal
district court but another Avenue is
available an administrative hearing
after which a negotiation and settlement
may follow and the the agreement says
that the complainant agrees she will not
disseminate or publish or cause anyone
else to disseminate or publish in any
manner disparaging words of family Tory
remarks are common to adverse to the
interests of Representative John Conyers
the office of Representative John
Conyers or any of the offices at present
or former employees a lot of members of
Congress have said that this raises
major concerns members have argued that
90 days is too long to make a person
continue working in the same environment
with their harasser that interns and
fellows should be eligible to pursue
complaints through this process and that
it is unfair for the victim to have to
pay for legal representation while the
office of the harasser is represented
for free by the houses counsel in this
case one of Conyers former employees was
offered a settlement in exchange for her
silence that we paid out of Conyers
taxpayer-funded office budget and then
they would rehire the woman as a
temporary employee and they would pay
her through employee funds so looked as
though she was still working and then
she was let go as opposed to there was a
settlement to let her go after she was a
sexually harassed the draft agreement
was unsigned congressional employment
agreements employment records matched
the timing and amount to outlined in the
document a law clerk who represented
complainant said the process was
disgusting he said it's a design
cover-up you feel they were betrayed by
their government just for coming forward
it's like being abused twice so well
done Congress for creating a process
that protects Congress people against
their own sexual misconduct apparently a
bunch of women have come forward about
Conyers apparently the employee said in
her affidavit the Conyers made sexual
advances toward her I was driving the
congressman my personal car and resting
my head on the stick shift
Conyers reached over McGann's crest my
hand in a sexual manner the woman said
she told Congress she was married and
not interested in pursuing a sexual
relation
chef's she said she was told by many too
many times by constituents it was well
known Conyers had sexual relationships
with his staff and said she and other
female staffers felt this undermined
their credibility a male employee said
he witnessed Conyers rub the legs and
other body parts of complainant in what
appeared to be a sexual and
inappropriate manner Conyers said he
needed to be more careful because bad
publicity would not be as helpful as he
runs for re-election he ends of the
conversation saying he would work on his
behavior just great behavior by another
another member of Congress so again
here's the process you have a hundred
eighty days to report your incidents
then you have mandatory counseling
mandatory counseling can be waived
apparently the employee is forced to
sign a confidentiality agreement to even
continue and then there's mandatory
mediation a mandatory cooling-off period
you file a formal complaint or you go to
federal district court or administrative
hearing so all of this is required to be
kept secret just a terrible process and
needs to be redone immediately Congress
protecting itself through all of this
meanwhile the media continue to protect
themselves to a certain extent Charlie
Rose is now under fire yes
yes I think you heard that correctly
Charlie Rose who is now 76 years old
again
amazing apparently eight women have told
The Washington Post that longtime TV
host Charlie Rose made unwanted sexual
advances on them including lewd phone
calls walking around naked and their
president are groping the breasts
buttocks or genital areas he's just a
charmer as Charlie Rose also it is worth
noting that the go-to move for a lot of
sexual harasser seems to be showing up
naked wearing a robe like apparently
once he needs to do this it's very weird
like I don't know why why guys think
this is attractive to women and though I
guess they've been watching too many
porn movies this idea that you show up
naked and a woman's just like oh yeah I
don't know what in the world would
possess men to believe this this is a
bunch of nonsense the woman were
employees are aspired to work for Rose
that Charlie rose from the late 1990s to
as recently as 2011 they ranged in age
from 21 to 37 at the time of the alleged
encounters roses now 75 the CBS canceled
his show PBS and bloomberg have also
dropped him five of the women spoke on
the condition of anonymity out of fear
of Rose's stature in the industry has
power over their careers and what they
described as volatile temper so I have a
few notes on all of this note number one
is it is amazing to see how many women
say the
the reason they didn't come forward is
because they were afraid of
repercussions within the industry and it
is true there are repercussions okay I
said this yesterday in Hollywood in
journalism in politics there are
repercussions for women who speak out
against people who sexually harass or
sexually assault them their names are
forever linked with these people it's
hard for them to get a job elsewhere
because now they try to apply for a job
and people at this new job say well
maybe the complaint was false maybe
she's just you know the kind of person
who's constantly complaining about
things and we don't want to hire her
she's a sexual harassment risk she's
gonna go to the HR she's gonna sue do we
really want to hire that person
so women stay silent but there's
something else and that is we in
American society you know it's funny we
all like to say well how did that all
these people these people knew this was
going on okay we all vaguely knew that a
lot of this was going on in politics
okay because it's always going on in
politics there are three types of you
know power here there's there's money
there's fame and there's power all three
of those exists in all three of these
professions journalism in in in
Hollywood and in politics and we have
idolized these people we have idolized
these people because we have to ask
ourselves a question why is it that so
many of these guys think they can get
away with this why did Charlie Rose
think he could get away with sexually
harassing 22 year old girls when he was
in his 70s why do you think he could get
away with just asking them to come over
his house and then showering publicly
naked and then hitting on them like what
made him think that it was okay well
misconduct thrives when there's no
accountability historically speaking
we've always had powerful men who
exhibit atrocious behavior typically
those were members of the aristocracy
typically those were Kings right those
are people who could actually exercise
power over somebody there are people who
could who could you know there's no real
evidence that Prime it knocked ever took
place the idea that Nobles would
actually go into peasant villages and on
the night of a wedding grab the bride
away and have sex with her that's sort
of mythical but the idea that it that
did exist came from peasants who were
saying this is how lords and ladies sort
of treat us that there are these heiress
the aristocrats that there are these
these landed classes who would treat
people badly because they had power over
you and how could you fail to to accede
to their requests I talked about that
that movie mud bound there's that
feeling not with regard to sex in the
movie but with regard to just generalize
treatment that if somebody has power
over you sometimes you got to keep your
head down
and there's nothing that you can say
about it so the question is in an egg
egg a latarian you know free association
society like ours why is it that so many
these guys thought they could get away
with it I mean you could see people
getting away with it in a time when
Kings could behead political opponents
at a time when aristocrats could throw
you off their land and ensure that you
never were able to work anywhere else
and you turned into starving beggar but
in an area where you know women are free
to work all over the United States and
various industries why were all of these
powerful men why did they believe they
could get away with it and why did they
get away with it and this is a sad truth
about Americans we treat our new
aristocracy the same way peasants
treated the old aristocracy with
deference right we treat Hollywood with
deference we treat politicians with
deference we treat journalists with
deference elite status in each of those
industries doesn't just mean that they
have opportunities for brutality but
there's a knowledge that if you engage
in this sort of brutality people are
going to look the other way a lot of
Americans seek to curry favor with the
powerful and so there's gonna be a lot
of opportunities for these guys to
engage in sexual misconduct does anyone
really think that women are dying to
meet Harvey Weinstein the reason women
wanted to meet Harvey Weinstein as they
thought that he could help their career
so that creates the opportunity for
misconduct and then there is the the non
the the the failure of consequences for
misconduct and that's because the public
offers no consequences sometimes victims
were blamed but I think a Bill Clinton
Monica Lewinsky sometimes victims were
blamed sometimes we were sometimes the
darkest side of humanity there's a dark
side of humanity where people do look
down on victims in certain situations
this happens throughout world history
where people are victimized and we look
down on them why didn't they stand up
for themselves or well you know she had
it coming this kind of disgusting
thought but we have to stop with the
idolatry okay you can't idolize the
aristocracy or whether you're talking
about the modern-day aristocracy or
whether you're talking about the
aristocracy that is existed historically
okay so that's that's point number one
point number two is I'm seeing this this
rush to me a call bond on Twitter and
it's really irritating so there's a guy
named Ben White who is the political
chief economic correspondent and he
tweeted this morning my gender is
terrible
well the good news is your gender is
fluid so you can change at any time Ben
but he says my gender is terrible time
politics editor Ryan League Beckwith
tweeted
Morning Glory yesterday not tweeting
tomorrow just retweeting women men join
me the idea being that men are
inherently pigs and evil if we just rush
forward to do so on our own sex then
therefore we all have done some
great-grand good right you get the same
thing from from white people in 10
there's a racist crime white person
against black person really got a bunch
of white people saying I'm ashamed for
my white privilige okay this is a trendy
habit yeah and and this is really
galling the reason that it's galling is
because it goes to something deeper here
you know conservatives traditionalists
they look at what's happening right now
in Hollywood and journalism and politics
and we say yeah yeah no no it's not a
surprise I'm sorry it's not a surprise
to anyone not just because prominent
people have always done this but because
human beings are inherently capable of
sin conservatives look at human beings
differently than people on the left two
people on the in conservative circles
particularly traditional and moral
circles they look at human beings and
they say we are all capable of sin men
particularly have certain sins that
attach to their nature men are more
driven to treat women like sex objects
and women are driven to treat men like
sex objects for example that's just the
way it is that's not an excuse and
that's not even a it's a justification
in the sense that that is how men are
but it's not an excuse for bad behavior
and that is why what conservatives say
is if men have a tendency to do this bad
thing that is why we must have
prophylactic rules this is why we have
to train men not to do these things and
train men to be gentlemen and set up
rules that protect women right that's
why conservatives are all about rules I
really do love the G K Chesterton notion
that the difference between the left and
the right is how we treat rules the
right comes to the left comes to a fence
in the middle of a field and says I see
no reason for this fence and they
dismantle the fence the right comes to
the fence in the middle of the in the
middle of the field they say I don't see
a reason for this fence I'm gonna go
learn what the reason for this fence is
and then if the reason is bad I'll
dismantle the fence okay that the the
fences that existed for thousands of
years were built up around the idea that
men were inherently sinful that men had
these drives and that you needed to
build fences around men specifically I
mean this is a very Torah based concept
of Judaic based concept the idea of
fences around the torii you're gonna
build up prophylactic rules that prevent
people from engaging in behavior they
otherwise would be Haven
you know conservatives have always said
that men left unchecked will act like
we recognize that men tend to see women
as potential sex objects and without
boundaries men would treat women as sex
objects but in order to combat that
behavior wasn't the conservative sat
around and nodded at that behavior we
said no here's a bunch of rules that can
help combat that behavior right here's
some of the rules right social
expectation that sex would be connected
with marriage that you would actually
have to commit to a woman in order to
have sex with her this is a very
conservative notion why was it
constructed to protect women to protect
women see no men going around and
victimizing women sexually the idea was
that women would not be expected to have
sex with men unless it was in the
confines of a committed relationship and
men would not be able to have sex with
women unless it was in the confines of a
committed relationship marriage was set
up to protect women it was not a
patriarchal institution for the
betterment of men most men are not
interested in commitment that's part of
human nature it's part of male nature
throughout species
hey encouragement of marriage prior to
sexual activity and as something
conservatives always said get married
before you have sex right that's how I
was brought up one of the reasons for
that is that you know a marriage
ceremony does it provides objective
measures of consent right that's what a
marriage ceremony is it is a man saying
in front of an entire community I am now
going to protect this woman and a woman
saying in front of an entire community I
am now going to be protected by this man
and I consent to our sexual relationship
that is an inherent part of marriage
okay that sort of objective knowledge is
good because the counts are suggestion
right think about it the counselor
suggestion is that it's not so clear
that consent has been had in non marital
situations where consent has not been
publicly proclaimed it's amazing we're
setting all these yes means yes rules
here in California we're setting up I
call them no means no rules there's no
what they are they're called yes means
yes rules in California yes means yes
rules are the you have to sit there with
with a contractual checklist you know
move down the checklist can I touch your
leg yes can I touch your butt yes
can I kiss you yes right in and now
we're gonna actually like go down the
checklist of course there's no proof of
this thing unless is actually written so
apparently you need a yes means yes
physical checklist in places like
California that's not number one how sex
works but number two what that's doing
is it's actually trying to do the same
thing that marriage did before marriage
was a public Proclamation then now you
are in a skid
and consensual sexual relationship with
someone and the implication was that
without that marriage we don't know we
don't know whether the woman can sense
it or not we just don't know
and that was sorta that was one of the
these sort of backhands and ideas behind
marriage yeah also the idea that we
would have carefully cultivated rules of
contact between men and women right now
not with regard to the workplace but in
many religions prescribe physical
contact right there's something in
Judaism called shomer negiah the idea is
that you're not supposed to actually
touch a woman even until you're married
you're not supposed to touch her now
most most people even in the I would say
most young Jewish guys in the modern
orthodox community don't hold by this
but the ideal is you set up these
prophylactic rules specifically so you
don't have mistreating women right there
there is a rule that is basically the
pence rule in Judaism it's called you
code and the idea is that you're not
supposed to be alone in a room with a
woman with the who to whom you are not
married with the door shut
specifically to minimize the possibility
of sexual misconduct by a man right all
of these things were based not on the
idea that men shouldn't control
themselves but based on the idea that a
lot of men don't control themselves and
that's why we should have rules
preventing men from getting into
situations that put women at risk right
that was the idea here right the left
wants to hold two simultaneous ideas men
are pegs and men can be T and men can be
taught not to be pigs and we can
maintain rules that don't restrict men
in any way that's idiotic
you know men are pegs are men are not
pegs or at least men have the capacity
to be pegs conservatism were all about
this idea that there were rules that men
could not be universally trusted to not
to sin against women you know let's put
it in in terms leftist can understand
you know they like gun control let's
call it male control complete with
background checks mandatory training a
fulsome male enforcement structure you
go ask dad for permission to marry the
girl if the if the girl is something bad
happens to her dad will come over and
beat the living crap out of you right
these were all based on sort of
conservative sexual notions not because
they're trying to victimize women but
precisely the opposite now here's what
the left said the left said men are
still mistreating women though you've
got all these rules and men are still
mistreating women it can't be that the
rules are not broad enough the rules are
too broad it must be that the rules
themselves are to blame for the
exploitation if we just retrained men if
we somehow perfected human nature and
made it to the men did
see women as sex objects anymore maybe
we could just teach men maybe we could
just re re enshrine certain basic
feminist notions in men then all of this
would go away and you know what else
we'll get rid of all these rules because
these rules are really just hallmarks of
a patriarchal past I don't see the
reason for this fence I'm removing this
fence in fact the fence maybe the reason
that people are jumping the fence did
you get rid of the fence maybe they
won't jump the fence anymore because
there won't be a fence so they got rid
of marriage was patriarchal a marriage
should top men that women were property
that's we had to kill marriage right
sexual taboos had taught men that women
were dangerous seductresses therefore we
have to kill those sexual taboos and
then men will go back to seeing women as
human beings full and upright as opposed
to sex objects chivalry had taught men
that women were weak and could be
exploited to get rid of chivalry did it
result as the left had thought no it did
not
no it did not and so now the left is ad
hoc trying to put new rules back in
place now the left is trying to put
rules that they're not even clear on
back in place I saw for example a poll
yesterday that show the 25% of American
women said that a man asking a woman for
a drink with sexual harassment is that a
less is that a more reasonable rule than
the idea that sex should be confined
within marriage is it really a
reasonable rule that if a guy asks a
girl for a drink that sexual harassment
or that if a guy says a girl says to a
girl that she looks pretty that this
constitutes sexual harassment is that
like the rules that the left are now
setting up are actually significantly
more Puritan than the rules that
conservatives set up over the course of
thousands of years that were tried and
tested and largely worked our women
safer now so we got rid of all the rules
and now we've constructed this new set
of rules that are completely in exact by
the way like absolutely an exact they're
really ad hoc that they're just made up
on the spot right if a woman gets drunk
with the guy they both have sex and they
both have a good time then it's totally
consensual and fine
if a woman a man both get drunk they
have sex the next morning the girl says
that that was terrible then it was rape
right how exactly are we supposed to
distinguish these rules that are set up
on the basis of radical subjectivism the
left has created a society where you
know that there are landmines everywhere
we don't know exactly where the
landmines are until it's too late and
you've stepped on one
in fact we learn where the landmines are
by people stepping on them now all of
this is not to say there shouldn't be
rules the case I'm making is that there
be consistent rules and the left is so
funny because it on the one hand they're
saying rules make people worse and on
the other hand they're setting up
through the back door all of these rules
that are in non equally applied
arbitrarily applied used to as a club to
beat down other people or or are
insufficient to protect women all of
these things in other words these sexual
behavior rules that have been set up by
the left are completely unworkable and
what's being shown right now is how
completely unworkable they are there is
no place more leftist than Hollywood
sexual harassment is a way of life here
okay I've lived my entire life in
Hollywood every woman that I know who
works in Hollywood has been sexually
harassed or assaulted I do not say this
with with any with any shred of
exaggeration every single one I do not
know any who have not been sexually
harassed or assaulted in Hollywood by
people for whom they worked generally I
really don't okay and I don't think
that's rare Hollywood this is maybe the
most common place in the world because
Hollywood is a meat market okay and men
treat it like a meat market and they
take the absence of these rules these
conservative rules they were supposed to
be chivalrous with regard to women
they're supposed to marry women before
they have sex with them they were
supposed to abide by certain careful
rules of conduct with regard to
male-female relationships they took all
of the 1960s morality turned it on its
head and abused women we're gonna talk
about that and deconstructing in culture
today we're gonna talk about how this
has pervaded the culture it's true in
journalism too journalism is a very left
field you're seeing all of these
powerful men in journalism doing exactly
the same thing all the woman's liberated
she's liberated she'll go out to her
drink with me we'll both get drunk and
then we'll go back to my place even
though I'm married we're liberated now
is that a protection for women or is
that an invitation to a problem
apologizing for men's gender is not
gonna help so the solution that we've
seen from some of these folks is what
effect just apologized for my gender you
know men are pigs okay that's a good
starting place but all people are
capable of sin which is why we need to
set up prophylactic rules there is a
purpose to rules okay only a proactive
reinstitution of checks and balances in
society is going to help and in order
for us to get there we're gonna have to
recognize that human behavior is not
eminently malleable in fact human
behavior is pretty rigid and the notion
that you can ignore the rigidity of
human behavior because you just wish to
and you wish it were different
that's not
help anybody okay with with all of that
said I know I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at Skillshare so right
now you're trying to get up a leg up at
work and you are trying to make your
resume better you are trying to improve
your earning potential you need to be
adding skills to your resume on a
regular basis you know when you send in
your resume there's a skill section it
says do you know this or that or this
skill share makes sure that you can fill
in that blank with a bevy of skills that
is what skills share is for they have 3
million members 17,000 classes it's
Netflix for online learning take classes
in graphic design DSLR photography
social media marketing digital
illustration and much more skill share
classes are taught by industry experts
experienced professionals perfect if
you're looking to build your career or
start the side hustle of your dreams I
have been taking some email marketing
classes and social media marketing
classes with people the office have been
doing the same so we all get better at
our jobs in the past I even took a
watercolor class Skillshare is giving my
listeners right now a one-month free
trial of unlimited access to over 17,000
classes each of these classes about 45
minutes really well taught easy to
understand go to skills shared calm /
capiro and start your free month today
that skill share calm / appear and you
get a free month make sure you use /
appear so you get the free month and
also so that they know that we sent you
okay so these are very serious topics
but we do not treat them seriously
because we don't treat anything
seriously in the United States anymore
we basically treat everything like a
joke sexual harassment becomes very
serious business when it's a political
opponents of yours when it's a political
ally then you just sort of brush it off
so there are a bunch of actresses on SNL
and writers and producers on SNL 36
women wrote a letter in support of Al
Franken who you know there's a picture
of grabbing the boobs of a sleeping
woman so he's a class act representative
Jackie Speier who has been talking about
how there are members of Congress who
are sexually depraved she comes out and
she says she's not gonna ask Franken to
resign Democratic commentator our
contributor Sally cone came out today
and tweeted time for Al Franken to go
wrong is wrong and the Democrats need to
show they strongly and consistently
stand for women's rights you are not
willing to go that far though just to be
clear you are not calling for his
resignation tonight well I may be
calling for his resignation at some
point but I think that just not yes what
I'm saying you're not there yet yes I'm
not there yet
she's not there so what exactly would
make her be there right nobody ever has
a consistent standard on what would make
you be there I've been pretty consistent
on this Democrats are simply not we
don't treat any of these subjects with
real seriousness we mock seriousness and
and then we suggest when when things get
really bad that we're gonna be serious
you watch within six months we will babe
we will be back to the fully partisan
reinterpretation of sexual harassment
and assault again
all right this feels like a turning
point it feels like an inflection point
in American culture and I hope that it
is because I think that pigs should be
cast out on their ear but so I think
that's really where this is going no
because I think too many people have a
stake in the current system and in
protecting men more importantly who have
engaged in impropriety under the current
system I think there are too many
members of the media too many members of
politics too many members in Hollywood
people who need to get away with this in
order for people to continue having
careers I don't think that that this is
gonna fundamentally transform the way
that the society works particularly
because we're not willing to reinstitute
rules that are actually answerable so
instead we're just gonna fall back on
stupidity and that's where we are now
last night and the speaking of stupidity
last night CNN had a 20-minute interview
with levar ball
levar ball is this this loudmouth
whose child's Lonzo ball plays for the
is that his name yeah yeah Lonzo ball he
plays for the Lakers and he has a
garbage jump shot he's basically benched
because he's shooting 30% from the field
he's you know just awful it's amazing me
he got drafted not knowing how to shoot
a basketball like this seems to me the
number one priority but in any case his
father levar had started he's made a
name for lawn so basically by being a
loudmouth and saying his son is better
than Michael Jordan which is absurd
Michael Jordan could shoot and play
defense and levar ball then took on
Donald Trump so his other son Lee Angelo
went to China and started shoplifting in
China which is a genius move and Trump
got him free and then Trump did what
from does he said I want to thank you
and Lee Angela wall gave him a thank you
but Lavar ball did not instead levar
ball ripped on president Trump which led
president from to suggest that he should
have left Lee Angelo in jail in China
which of course is very mature and then
CNN decided that it was necessary to
have a 20 minute interview with levar
ball which is just I'm not I'll just
play some of this and you'll see how
stupid the media are then you wonder why
we can't take serious issues seriously
because the same people who are
discussing the quote-unquote serious
issues are in too
Lavar ball for 20 minutes I would say
thank you if he would have put him on
his plane and took him on then I would
have said Thank You mr. Trump for taking
my boys out of China and bringing them
back to the US there's a lot of room on
that plane I would have said thank you
kindly for that so because he wouldn't
take this wonderful say you know thank
you well well just saying that's how I
will say thank you I'm just saying you
might say thank you a different way you
just say thank you like it's no it's not
how you say thank you when what now
so so only it's a president from get
them out of jail in China but the
problem is the Blaine ride solovar ball
obviously a member of higher
intelligence and work even Shannon
Sharpe who has come in for serious
criticism on ben shapiro show before
even he says um levar you're being an
idiot I can assure you even though the
people that dislike President Trump the
most would agree that lebar ball is in
the wrong in this situation I guarantee
you that you might dislike what he's
done what he said and who he is but what
he he had some effect on these kids
coming home it sure seemed like it who
was your son your son the one they'd
gotten rather than Trump involved in
this you should have been over there
opening up 15 25 pop-up stores hopefully
selling thousands and thousand pairs of
sneakers but your son couldn't keep his
hands to himself good for shannon sharpe
okay so so I mean when even shannon
sharpe is critiquing your intelligence
then you know that you've really fallen
low Lavar balls so well done media for
it 20 minutes 20 minutes I mean my god
what a desert wasteland cable television
has become a move our ball can fill 20
minutes on your show speaking of stupid
things Kathy Griffin is still out there
complaining and suggesting i don't wow
she Kathy Griffin is out there saying
that she's been victimized by you know
Hollywood is very very pro Trump you
know this right you don't know this cuz
not true oh yeah so so it turns out that
she says she's not been able to get any
work since holding up a severed head of
President Trump a mock-up of a severed
head of President Trump that has less to
do with the fact that Hollywood likes
Trump's they don't then the fact that
Kathy Griffin is terrible at her job but
now she's making a living running around
complaining about how everyone is mean
to her so here we go I think I should be
able to get my life back so I know I
took a picture that offended a lot of
people but this wall of crap has never
fallen on any woman in the history of
America like it has on me so and by the
way I know about Eartha Kitt and I very
much encourage you to look her up
but even Eartha Kitt didn't have like
FoxNews she's the most victimized woman
in American history do you see her hotel
room like no she's not the most
victimized woman in American history
okay she's not even staying in a motel 6
like every person has stayed at Motel
sex is more victimized than Kathy
Griffin she's most victimized woman in
American history in American history
according to Kathy Griffin no wall of
crap has ever fallen on anyone more not
even like the five year old black girls
were attempting to go to school and an
integrated school in Birmingham even
those girls that the wall of crap never
fell on anyone quite like it fell on
Kathy Griffin just astonishing
self-centeredness in our media and guess
what this is what we'll go back to okay
the default here this is what's so angry
the default here is not seriousness
about serious topics the default is
Kathy Griffin and Lavar ball that's the
default and the media will go back there
and we'll forget about all the sexual
harassment stuff I fear you know why
because there's no rooted morality in
the United States that requires us to
abide by moral rules there is no rooted
morality that says you as a human being
are worth more than this women and men
that you have a soul you have an
immortal soul and you are required by
God by nature you are required to treat
other human beings with respect and
decency because they are worthy of
respect and decency we are an
entertainment culture that treats people
as disposable commodities and then were
shocked when people are treated as
disposable commodities we should be
shocked because every so often were
shocked into awake into into an awake
state I have a feeling we're gonna fall
back asleep again which is really
horrifying okay I have much more to say
on this topic and others we're going to
do a significant deconstructing of the
culture today involving many old songs
that you will recognize but have never
really listened to the lyrics to or if
you have and you let them get away with
it then shame on you but we'll talk
about all of that you have to subscribe
for that $9.99 a month gets you
subscription to the ben shapiro show it
means that you get the rest of the show
live on video it means the rest of
andrew Clavin Stroh live on video means
the rest of Michael Noel's
live on video you get to be part of our
mailbag here on Friday get all your
questions answered we do live questions
on the show for those who have not
participated plus when we have
conversations special Q&A sessions you
get special privileges the Shapiro store
will be opening soon I keep promising it
it actually is happening it's going to
be a thing and you will get discounts
when you become a member also if you get
the annual subscription you get this the
very finest you know all vessels for
beverage right is the it is better than
the flagon with the Dragon it is better
than the vessel with the pestle it is
better than the chalice from the palace
is the leftist here's hot or cold
tumbler if you can't get any of those
references
go watch the court jester the greatest
company of all time in any case this
this comes with a $99 annual
subscription and you will also get all
of the other privileges as well if you
just want to watch the show later go to
youtube you won't see the end of the
show but you'll see the beginning of the
show and you can listen to it on audio
please subscribe we have some awesome
new videos coming out including a
Thanksgiving video that should be out
what tomorrow or Thursday is that yeah
be on Thanksgiving which I in which I
explain what I am thankful for this year
believe it or not I am thankful for a
few things and you also can subscribe to
the show at iTunes or SoundCloud or
Google Play or wherever you can get your
podcast make sure to subscribe and
download the show and leave us a review
it always helps with outranking we
really appreciate it we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
all righty okay so I want to briefly
discuss a more serious topic and that is
more service than Kathy Griffin and
lebar ball anyway and that is this AT&T
deal so there has been a lot of talk
about the DOJ the Trump DOJ is going to
crack down there they're filing a
lawsuit to stop the merger of AT&T in
Time Warner so it's not Time Warner
Cable it's just Time Warner the
entertainment company the reason that
that the DOJ is supposedly stepping in
is because what they fear is that AT&T
is a distribution network right they'd
sell your Internet and they give you
your cable and then they are going to
privilege Time Warner content because
they own Time Warner content so they
make double box right so if you
subscribe to HBO and you pay AT&T then
AT&T is basically buying HBO and that
means that you're paying AT&T twice the
the government really has no business
here I don't think that this is an
antitrust violation I think the vast
majority of so-called antitrust
violations do not exist in order for
there to be a monopoly you have to have
100 percent to ownership over a
particular area of American commerce
AT&T and Time Warner aren't even in the
same industry
AT&T is and distribution industry it's
vertical integration 80s in the
distribution network and Industry and
Time Warner's in the entertainment
industry it's the equivalent of AT&T
buying MGM right they're not the same
thing at all
and one acquiring the other actually in
some ways can make commerce better it'll
make it cheaper because AT&T presumably
can charge less for HBO if you're an
AT&T subscriber and also agency does not
control the telecommunications market
AT&T is in competition with Verizon
they're in competition with Sprint
they're in competition with a bunch of
other different companies and Time
Warner obviously is in competition with
a lot of other networks including Fox
News what this has led some people to
believe is the real reason that Trump is
cracking down that the DOJ is cracking
down is because Time Warner contains CNN
and Trump doesn't like CNN so he's
trying to damage CNN the DOJ apparently
wanted Time Warner to sell CNN away from
Time Warner to separate it off before it
sold itself to AT&T Jeffrey Toobin at
CNN explains this this is gonna be
relevant let's be blunt here the
President of the United States hates CNN
he's been tweeting you know about trains
hitting people wearing CNN signs I mean
actual violence against CNN so I mean
this is not some some like speculation
on my
part the president has said it over and
over again that he despises the place
where we work so that's relevant okay
and I think that that is going to be
relevant in these court cases it's why
you know President Trump really should
not have been speaking out about about
CNN and then using that as an excuse I
mean he'll say things like the
Washington Post Amazon be so's
consortium and then if you had cracked
out on Washington Post you'd have to
imagine that it had less to do with law
than it had to do with bias now the same
thing is sort of true of CNN he's free
to criticize CNN but he was talking
openly during the campaign about how
much he hated CNN and then in the same
breath saying that CNN Time Warner's
trying to make a deal with AT&T that's
not good stuff okay time for some things
I like and then some things I hate and
then we have a pretty significant
deconstructing the culture today so
things that I like so often threatened
to cut the show short because this is in
things I like today but it is indeed in
things I like Justice League's and
things I like it's not things I love
okay it wasn't a great movie it's not
even I wouldn't say it's like a good
movie I would say that it's an enjoyable
movie right there parts of the movie
that are enjoyable the villain in the
movie is garbage okay then the worst
part of the movie is that the villain
Steppenwolf is just in nothing of a
villain right I mean he's like a stock
character he's a 2d character directly
from not even a comic book directly from
like a sketch pad like Steppenwolf is
bad the cgi here has some real problems
because they overuse it well I don't
understand why Hollywood thinks that
that overuse of CGI is better than
sparing use of CGI the best scenes in
this movie you CGI sparingly they don't
overuse it
but like the entire conclusion the last
I don't know why every movie now seems
like we have to have a monster fight at
the end that involves tremendous use of
CGI which is not my thing so those are
the things about it that I don't like
the other thing I don't like about it is
that Ben Affleck who appears to have
developed a serious case of fat face is
is he I thought in the last Batman V
Superman which I thought was wildly
underrated by the way I thought it was
really mistreated by people at the
theaters the director's cut is actually
a good movie the director's cut is a
very enjoyable movie it is not a forty
percent on Rotten Tomatoes movie it is a
65 percent movie to me Batman V Superman
it's I watched it twice okay I'm not
gonna see Justice League twice I don't
think it was as good the only truly
horrifying DC movie that I've seen in
the last four years I was Suicide Squad
which is truly
piece of rotten pernicious garbage I
mean it's just horrible but this is not
that okay it definitely has its moments
the problem I have here is that Ben
Affleck and Batman V Superman play sort
of the Frank Miller Batman right this
guy who really enjoys making other
people suffer and his kind of a sadist
which is kind of fun in this one he
turns into basically a block of wood he
turns back into Ben Affleck in this one
and he is clearly trying to hand over
the reins of leadership to Wonder Woman
because gal gadot is a breakout star
right she's she's terrific and she's
really a magnetic on screen the good
things about this film
the introduction of the flash I think
has actually done in a fun way
I like the Flash's character in this
there's one particular shot that is very
very funny in which the flash is sort of
the geeky member of the group he's you
know it's not given it's not a giveaway
when you look at the poster and you see
that that Superman's logo is included in
the poster it's not a giveaway that
Superman appears in the film but there's
a point where the flash meets Superman
let's put it this way when they meet
it's very funny there's there's one
there's one little bit that's very very
funny I thought that they did the
introduction of cyborg is actually quite
well done so I'm not a huge cyborg fan
in the comics but I thought that they
did a decent job with cyborg I thought
they really did a poor job with Aquaman
Aquaman is one of the cooler characters
in the comics when they basically turned
him into an annoying surfer dude he
actually has some depth in the comics
because he's a man stuck between two
worlds right he's sort of half Aquaman
half human and they don't really do that
but and in case here's some of the
preview
[Music]
yes let me just say right here this is
the good stuff in the movie right the
character stuff in the movie is good
I'll take that as a yes what the ring
Superman violence acts of war and
terrorism are all on the rise I had a
dream it was the end of the world
[Music]
I think it's something more okay so the
CGI sort of battles the preview is
actually better than the film the the
CGI battles that you see there are not
particularly good they kind of stink
actually but it has its moments
it's not a great movie by any stretch of
the imagination but it is I have a basic
rule of thumb as I say and when it comes
to Rotten Tomatoes if you want to use
the Rotten Tomatoes score as sort of a
proxy for how good a movie is you have
to subtract 20 points from every Marvel
movie and add 20 points to have a DC
movie for some reason DC there's a real
bias against DC in the critical
community again I don't think this is a
great movie but I don't think it's a
garbage movie and the way that they made
out Batman V Superman particularly was
that it was a garbage movie I don't
think that's exactly correct okay other
things that I like so this was just
funny so yesterday they they knocked
down the the Georgia Dome in Atlanta and
this was much awaited The Weather
Channel set up across the street the
reason they set up across the street is
obviously they're trying to see over
this this kind of cement barrier that
you can see there and if they set up too
close and they don't have the right
angle so they set up across the street
they're about to blow the dome and then
this happens
[Laughter]
and that it's God so people people
started photoshopping that bus into
various other events like they had the
bus driving in the driving in front of
the game-winning hit from last year's
World Series and they had the bus
driving in front of like historic events
just just as you're about to see them
like the moon landing they the bus just
driving in front of the camera pretty
spectacular stuff very very funny okay
time for a couple of quick things that I
hate so thing that I hate number one
comes courtesy of a person who I think
is awful Joy Behar so Joy Behar on the
execrable show the view which is just
and the combined IQ on that show has got
to still be in double digits I mean it
is just a horrific show every time I say
that I know I'm foreclosing my
possibility of appearing on the view but
I really doubt that I'd ever get an
invitation on the view because I mean
let's be let's be real about this if the
view ever invited me on it would be the
most entertaining hour of television in
the history of television I mean it
would be unbelievable so the view if you
want to double your ratings have me on
for an hour and see how it goes but just
because of that they won't ever have me
on the view in any case Joy Behar
trotted out this old tired argument that
I'm so sick of hearing from people on
the left it's so stupid it's untrue here
is ears Joy Behar system thrown away
when you think of a lot of these people
who are anti-choice they're very big on
the fetus but as soon as the child is
born one they don't vote for additional
help for the mother and the child they
don't want to pay now they won't pay for
that but he just want to fight for the
right now they're really only interested
in you before you're born once you're
born Your Honor on what it is this kid
that you're demanding I have okay okay
so we can stop it there
let me start okay yeah I'm demanding you
have a case so let me make this let's
put this in the context of adult
conversation now we're talking about
adults I don't want you to murder your
spouse I think it's a bad idea
to murder your spouse do I have to adopt
your spouse is it now - essa t-that I
have to bring your spouse into my home
and provide for your spouse or do I just
think it's a violation of Human Rights
for you to murder your spouse this idea
that in order for me to say you
shouldn't murder your baby that I have
to pay for your baby is so nonsensical
now we can have arguments as to what is
the best policy for children we can have
arguments over whether there is a real
problem of incentivizing women to have
children out of wedlock when the
government is going to pay for them
because the single motherhood rate has
skyrocketed in the year since welfare
was instituted and we can ask these
questions we can say is this policy the
best one for incentivizing men to stay
in the home and raise their children
alongside women we can say are these
policies sustainable right these are all
real questions we can have are they
generous enough should we do more for
children right these are questions that
we can ask does that have anything to do
with murdering the baby this idea that I
don't want you to kill someone and
therefore I have to make them a part of
my immediate family or pay for them is
insipid it's insipid it's like saying
that if you wanted to free the slaves in
the South in 1863 well I don't see you
adopting slaves into your family I don't
see you taking that slave and maeín
letting a marry your kid how about I
don't like people being enslaved like
this utter disconnection it's a complete
non sequitur but it's something that the
left loves to use because they're trying
to responsibility for the idea that it's
fine for a woman to kill our baby
because she's poor that's that's really
what they're saying here they're really
saying that if I'm not gonna pay for
your baby you should be allowed to kill
your baby which is an insane argument
that they would never actually make but
that's really what they're saying if you
get to the root of the logic that is the
logic that they are using okay other
things that I hate there's a New York
Times op-ed today saying that Charles
Manson was actually a member of the
right this is insipid okay Charles
Manson was not a Prada it was called
Charles Manson was not a product of the
counterculture what's funny about this
column is that when you actually read
the column you can see that the author
is getting so close to saying something
true and then shiz away from the true
thing so the author is is a is a person
named what Baynard woods he's a reporter
an editor of the real news network
whatever that is and the piece says the
Manson murders are often thought to mark
the end of the 1960s as if those brutal
slayings were the inevitable
of the counterculture the dark
consequence of long hair free love
casual druggies in a general breakdown
of authority and social norms yeah yeah
the sentiment was most famously
expressed by Joan Didion in her book The
White Album she wrote in a sense it was
true that the sixties ended abruptly on
August 9 1969 that's when the Manson
murders took place and then at the exact
moment when word of the murders on Cielo
Drive traveled like brush fryer through
the community when Damien was right we
talked about this yesterday
Charles Manson was hanging out with the
leading lights of his musical generation
Charles Mann that the Beach Boys
recorded a Charles Manson song I think
Clavin played it on his show yesterday
ok the Charles Manson was part and
parcel of the leftist culture but here's
what's funny right Wood says Manson was
a racist and a sexist and therefore he
must have been a right-winger wretches
like he all right he says mr. Manson was
not the endpoint of the counterculture
if anything he was a backlash against
the civil rights movement and a
harbinger of white supremacist race
warriors like Dylan Ruth the lunatic
fringe of the alright now what's
hilarious is that he stops one step
short it is true Manson was a racist and
a sexist and if you read his views on
race war they sound a lot like the views
of the alt-right that part is true but
he was also a member of the left let's
connect these two ideas is it possible
that the all right in many ways is an
outgrowth of the left is that a
possibility before you dismiss that
possibility recognize that the alt-right
has been supremely critical supremely
critical of constitutional conservatism
they've been supremely critical of
individualism they say that they are for
an identity politics for white people
that is much closer in notion and
orientations when identity politics of
race that the left embraces than it is
to an identity politics embraced by the
right it's one of the reasons why I find
the alt-right so repulsive and
disgusting okay time to deconstruct a
little bit of culture so we're looking
at our culture right now and we are
saying it's a smoking garbage fire it's
a smoking rubble heap of sexual assault
and harassment where could this possibly
have come from where would we see some
early indicators that maybe this was
going to happen and then you listen to
rock music so half of rock music in the
1960s apparently was dedicated to the
proposition that a 25 year old shtupping
a 14 year old was fine
the destruction of traditional sexual
mores the destruction of the idea that
there were certain rules you shouldn't
break in that
cent was not the only standard was
replaced with this free-flowing era of
free love where basically if you said
that it was fine to have sex with a girl
and the girl said ok then it was fine so
if you go back to Animal House there's
an actual scene in Animal House and that
is played for Laughs in which one of the
characters I believe is Tom Hall's has
sex with is it's a 13 year old girl in
Animal House on the 50-yard line yeah he
has sex like a 13 year old girl and it's
played for laughs right in the middle of
Animal House that's it that's part of
the plot and that's treated is totally
normal right he he doesn't know that she
doesn't know how old she is but it's
totally fine right it's totally fine
it's played as it's just sort of a funny
oops my bad if you look back at the film
shampoo with Warren Beatty Carrie Fisher
who is I think 18 at the time is playing
younger than 18 she supposed to be
playing 16 or 17 and she just has a
casual sexual encounter with Warren
Beatty no problem it's all fine right
this was the ethos of the 1960's and
1970's and you see it in the music right
even this song by the Beatles I saw her
standing there's still a popular old
ballad right I saw her stand not really
a ballad but it is still a popular song
I saw her standing there's played on The
Ed Sullivan Show ok listen to the lyrics
for a second okay listen just the
meaning of the lyrics
[Music]
okay so the first lyric there she was
just 17 if you know what I mean okay if
you know what I mean was apparently like
a side note added by John Lennon the age
of consent in Britain at the time was 16
so when they say if she was just 17 if
you know what I mean what they mean is
she's not 17 right she's just 17 but
we're gonna pretend she says she's not
17 we're gonna pretend she's 17 for
purposes of this sexual encounter right
man it's really what the song is about
and it's not rare okay Ted Nugent had a
song called jailbait it's pretty
horrific song right here's Ted Nugent
doing doing jailbait and I will tell you
what the lyrics are
[Music]
[Applause]
okay it continues along these lines
jailbait you look so good to me jailbait
won't you set me free the lyrics
continue well I don't care if you're
just thirteen you thirteen you'll yeah
that's the lyrics well I don't care if
you're just thirteen you look too good
to be true I just know that you're
probably clean there's one little thing
I got to do to you okay this is in the
lyrics and then later he says that maybe
he'll go after her mom and then the
police show up right and he says wait a
minute officer wait a minute officer
don't put those handcuffs on me what
about her hey I'll share her with you
okay this is part of the lyric of
jailbait by a huge star Ted Nugent who
was recently at the White House by the
way which shows you how our culture has
has you know basically included you know
a bunch of people who probably would
have been in jail for singing this sort
of tune in in 1930 in any case this is
not the only one here is a song from
kiss right the song is Christine sixteen
from kiss
[Music]
I've gotta
she's been around but she's young and
clean I've got to have her I can't live
without her whoa no Christine sixteen
Christine sixteen and then you wonder
where this permissive culture came from
you wonder where this culture of sexual
abuse came from you wonder why it is
that men see women as objects when
they're seeing thirteen-year-old girls
as sex objects and when this culture is
celebrating them for this these are all
huge hits these are all major bands I'm
not going far field and getting Aleksei
tannic death metal okay these are all
major bands kiss is a major band The
Beatles are a major bands head Newton
was a major star and the way you can see
that radicalism has been mainstreamed is
I mean not to put too fine a point on it
but gene Simmons of KISS was on Fox News
regularly for years okay Ted Nugent was
at the White House the Beatles are
worshipped worshipped okay this is the
way our culture works and then we turn
around and worship when we're shocked
when the bottom of the culture falls out
we're shocked by this you can't have it
both ways folks you can't have a full
sexual revolution in which you've tear
out every fence available and you
celebrate the people tearing out those
fences as liberators you greet them as
liberators when in fact they are great
annihilators okay we'll be back here
tomorrow with all of the latest end for
our last show before the Thanksgiving
Day weekend so be here are basically
maple do the mail bag early who didn't
mail bag early probably will do the mail
bag early tomorrow so that should be fun
okay so we'll do that tomorrow be here
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]